[Music]
in the 1980s a bonobo named kanzi
learned to communicate with humans to an
unprecedented extent
not through speech or gestures but using
a keyboard
of abstract symbols representing objects
and actions
by pointing to several of these in order
he created sequences to make requests
answer verbal questions from human
researchers and refer to objects that
weren't physically present kansi's
exploits ignited
immediate controversy over one question
had kanzi learned language
what we call language is something more
specific than communication language is
about sharing what's in our minds
stories opinions questions the past or
future
imagined times or places ideas it is
fundamentally
open-ended and can be used to say an
unlimited number of things
many researchers are convinced that only
humans have language
that the calls and gestures other
species use to communicate
are not language each of these calls and
gestures
generally corresponds to a specific
message for a limited total number of
messages
that aren't combined into more complex
ideas
for example a monkey species might have
a specific warning call that corresponds
to a particular predator like a snake
but with language there are countless
ways to say
watch out for the snake so far no animal
communication
seems to have the open-endedness of
human language we don't know for sure
what's going on in animals heads
and it's possible this definition of
language or our ways of measuring it
don't apply to them but as far as we
know only humans have language
and while humans speak around 7 000
distinct languages
any child can learn any language
indicating that the biological machinery
underlying language is common to all of
us
so what does language mean for humanity
what does it
allow us to do and how did we come to
have it
exactly when we acquired this capacity
is still an open question
chimps and bonobos are our closest
living relatives
but the lineage leading to humans split
from the other great apes more than
four million years ago in between there
were many species
all of them now extinct which makes it
very difficult to know
if they had language or anything like it
great apes give one potential clue to
the origins of language though
it may have started as gesture rather
than speech
great apes gesture to each other in the
wild much more freely than they vocalize
language may have begun to take shape
during the pleistocene
two to three million years ago with the
emergence of the genus
homo that eventually gave rise to our
own species
homo sapiens brain size tripled and
bipedalism freed the hands for
communication
there may have been a transition from
gestural communication
to gestural language from pointing to
objects and pantomiming
actions to more efficient abstract
signing
the abstraction of gestural
communication would have removed the
need for visuals
setting the stage for a transition to
spoken language
that transition would have likely come
later though
articulate speech depends on a vocal
tract of a particular shape
even our closest ancestors the
neanderthals and denisovans
had vocal tracts that were not optimal
though they likely had some vocal
capacity
and possibly even language only in
humans
is the vocal tract optimal spoken words
free the hands for activities
such as tool use and transport so it may
have been the emergence of speech
not of language itself that led to the
dominance of our species
language is so intimately tied to
complex thought
perception and motor functions that it's
difficult to untangle its
biological origins some of the biggest
mysteries remain
to what extent did language as a
capacity shape humanity
and to what extent did humanity shape
language
what came first the vast number of
possible scenarios we can envisage
or our ability to share them
at ted we're passionate about public
speaking
that's why the ted-ed team created an
app to help you
mine your life experience for ideas and
stories
worth sharing and then craft those
experiences
into compelling presentations it's
called ted
masterclass and you can learn more and
download the app
at ted.com masterclass